[Music]
here's your money briefing from Monday
July 24th I'm J.R Wellen for the Wall
Street Journal
rumors who maintained a high credit
score during their working years often
see those scores come down after they
retire
wsj personal finance reporter Amani
Louise joins me so Amani why does having
a high credit score matter
well your credit score is a measure of
your credit worthiness so anytime you
apply for a loan credit card the banks
pull your credit report and they look at
your score and that determines how much
interest you'll pay but what's the trend
here how do credit scores typically
change during one's retirement years so
your credit score typically goes up for
every decade of your life until your 70s
so after your 70s it Peaks at 762 and
then there's a slight drop in your 80s
to 756. the credit score is a
three-digit number that people place a
lot of importance on what goes into
making up the credit score there's a lot
of misconceptions about what goes into a
credit score and I got a really helpful
graphic from FICO and they break down
the calculation so it's 35 of your score
is based on your payment history that's
the biggest and most important factor
then 30 percent is your accounts owed so
that's how much credit you have how much
debt you have 15 the length of your
credit history
ten percent your mix of credit so that's
having installment loans and revolving
debt like a credit card and then ten
percent new credit so that's how many
credit inquiries are hitting your
account so what would drive down
someone's credit score in retirement
credit scores are a combination of a
number of factors and one of those
factors is your credit mix according to
fico's analysis borrowers who have a mix
of different kinds of loans are better
at repaying their bills so that means a
mix of credit cards auto loans mortgages
really revolving versus installment but
once you're in retirement you're less
likely to do things like buy a new car
and have an auto loan and you probably
paid off your mortgage years ago so just
based on the fact that you have fewer
kinds of debt that may hurt your score
but retirement is supposed to be all
about Financial Freedom why is a high
credit score important to retirees well
increasingly credit reports and credit
scores are being used in different
Industries so for example Health Care
when you're trying to get admitted to
assisted living facility they can pull
your credit report and if they feel like
you're not a good credit risk you won't
be admitted and another factor is
insurance insurance companies also use
credit based scores which can help
determine how much you pay for premiums
some people see their credit score and
they might see a change from month to
month and they follow it in in a
granular fashion like in 756 757 758
doesn't matter in those steps and how
someone's credit score might change it
depends on what range your credit score
is in and how much it's dropping so we
talked about average scores across
different decades and yes there is this
drop from 762 in your 70s to 756 in your
80s but that nine point drop isn't
likely to have a huge material impact on
whatever your financing options would be
or anything else that your credit score
is being used to qualify for however if
you drop below 660. they call it
subprime yes it's what most lenders
consider to be a low score or not good
score then that's when you'll start to
feel the impacts okay but retirees have
Decades of credit history wouldn't that
work to their advantage in terms of
their credit score you're right and
credit history is actually the biggest
factor in determining your credit score
but there's a lot of actions that
retirees make that make really good
Financial sense that could actually hurt
your credit score so for example if you
have a really old credit card and you've
paid it off maybe you don't want to deal
it with it anymore you want to
consolidate your debt so you shut that
card down if that card ends up
shortening your average credit history
length that could hurt your score so how
can retirees help keep their credit
scores up in their later years don't
close your old accounts and that's
really good advice for anyone but for
retirees it's important to remember
because it feels like you're making a
responsible good financial decision if
you're closing out all debts and maybe
simplifying your debt to make it easier
you don't have to keep track of
different statements and things like
that but you need to understand that
could have an adverse impact on your
score especially if the account that
you're closing is decades old so I spoke
to one retiree who's 67 years old living
in Kentucky and he really prided himself
on his credit score but he's seen his
credit score kind of Whiplash the most
it ever has since retiring well why did
it Whiplash well he'll say his wife made
a mistake while the couple was on
vacation they took a two-week trip to
Europe to celebrate their retirement and
she forgot to pay a bill while they were
out of the country and when he got back
he realized that his score had plunged
from being in the 800s to below 740. he
realized what happened and tried to call
the lender to get it removed from his
credit report but they said that he was
out of luck so he got really angry and
he closed that account and that was a
credit card he had opened since the 80s
so the legacy of that card just went
away it went away I think he said his
first credit cards was a JCPenney card
and a Sears card so that dates it right
there that's Wall Street Journal
personal finance reporter Amani moiz and
that's your money briefing I'm J.R
Whalen for the Wall Street Journal
[Music]
foreign